one of the categories of plotting the
rational numbers on the number line is
when the numerators are less than the
denominators let's try to plot 1 by 2
and minus 1 by 2 on the number line
first we see how we can plot 1 by 2 the
numerator 1 is less than the denominator
2 when the numerator is less than the
denominator the positive rational number
will be between 0 & 1 so we draw the
number line like this the number 1 by 2
has to lie somewhere between 0 & 1 now
we divide the length between 0 & 1 in
two equal parts how many equal parts is
the question the denominator tells us
the number of equal parts the
denominator is 2 so we divide it into
two equal parts this line divides this
region into two equal parts but what
does the numerator tell us it tells us
the number of parts starting from 0 the
numerator is 1 and therefore we take one
part from 0 and mark 1 by 2 here we can
use the same procedure to mark minus 1
by 2 on the left side of 0 divide it
into two parts and Mark minus 1 by 2 one
part away from 0
just as integers had corresponding
values rational numbers to have
corresponding values in our example
minus 1 by 2 corresponds to 1 by 2 let
us look at another example where the
numerator is less than the denominator
we have to plot 3 by 4 and minus 3 by 4
let us plot 3 by 4 first since the
numerator is less than the denominator
we know that the number will be between
0 & 1 so we draw the number line like
this with just 0 & 1 plotted remember
the denominator tells us the number of
equal parts since the denominator is 4
we divide the length between 0 & 1 into
4 equal parts
drawing these three lines gives us four
equal parts now we move to the numerator
the numerator tells us the number of
parts from the number zero since the
numerator is three we move three equal
parts from zero one two and three so we
mark three by four here now let us plot
minus three by four since 3 is less than
4 and the rational number is negative we
know that will come between 0 and minus
1 we divide this length into four equal
parts as the denominator is 4 and we
mark minus 3 by 4 3 parts away from zero
that's it we have plotted the points but
let me ask you a question
you have plotted the numbers 3 by 4 and
minus 3 by 4 but do you know which
numbers are plotted on these points
here's your answer since this is one
part we mark 1 by 4 here since these are
two parts we mark 2 by 4 here similarly
we can plot minus 1 by 4 and minus 2 by
4 here this was just for your
understanding and you don't need to mark
all the points if you're asked to mark
just 3 by 4 and minus 3 by 4 in the next
video we will look at an example in
which the numerator is greater than the
denominator
you
you